oui
il
on
lui
bonsoir je vais commencer par vous faire
participer
alors qui parmi vous c'est déjà laissé
tenter par un bon petit dessert en fin
de repas voilà au quai quasiment tout le
monde qui parmi vous c'est déjà
retourner dans la rue au passage d'une
jolie femme ou d'un joli garçon
bravo ok encore quasiment tout le monde
qui parmi vous a déjà souffert d'un
trouble psychique à et voilà vous êtes
quand même beaucoup moins nombreux
quatre ou cinq personnes en même temps
je vous comprends pas ce qu'il ya des
petites vulnérabilité qui sont faciles à
avouer et puis on a d'autres qui sont
quand même beaucoup plus compliqué a
révélé au public et je voulais aussi
remercier ceux qui ont levé la main
parce que c'était courageux et pourtant
toutes les enquêtes le prouve que ce
soit en france ou dans tout le monde
1 une personne sur quatre connaîtra dans
sa vie au moins une fois un trouble
psychique plus ou moins sévères et
personne n'en parle c'est un énorme
enjeu de société
et c'est aussi un énorme tabou je me
suis pas mal pris la tête pour préparer
ce speech parce que j'ai beaucoup de
choses à dire sur ce sujet et je
voudrais pas louper cette occasion si
rare d'en parler je vais vous raconter
une anecdote comme la majorité d'entre
vous je pense j'ai fait le celsa et je
ne suis passionné pour les ressources
humaines et dans mon parcours j'ai
rencontré beaucoup de drh
j'ai entendu aussi beaucoup de discours
sur les grandes valeurs humanistes qui
devait fonder une politique rh digne de
ce nom
j'ai entendu beaucoup de mots aussi vous
savez les mots compétences motivation
engagement diversité et le mot fragilité
va jamais
c'est vrai nom mais c'est sûr on souffre
jamais dans l'entreprise c'est connu
personne n'est mal personne le stress
personnes les sous pression bien sûr
alors si si si il ya un domaine dans
lequel j'ai entendu parler de ce mot là
c'est celui de l'insertion des personnes
handicapées dans le monde du travail
alors du coup bah j'en ai fait mon
métier en tant que consultante dans le
monde du handicap
je suis amené à travailler
principalement avec des drh celui d'une
grande entreprise pour une de mes
premières missions me confie la
réalisation d'un diagnostic pour mieux
intégrer le handicap dans son entreprise
et puis accessoirement aussi respecter
l'obligation légale pour ceux qui savent
pas apparemment vous riez donc ça veut
dire que vous le savez mais pour ceux
qui savent pas toutes les entreprises de
plus de 20 salariés doivent compter au
moins 6% de travailleurs handicapés dans
leurs effectifs alors dans le cadre de
cette mission je suis amené à rencontrer
le top management vous savez ceux qui
gèrent des milliers de salariés je me
retrouve dans le bureau d'une directrice
d'une principales l'une des principales
filiales de l'entreprise
et là je rencontre une dame hyper sympa
hyper motivés vous savez dynamique hyper
sympa il me dit comme ça me fait lui si
on tient là un sujet fondamental
vraiment moi je suis convaincu de
l'importance de la bonne gestion du
handicap dans l'entreprise alors vous
pouvez compter sur moi le si on va faire
du bon travail
oui yes moi je me dis quoi comment j'ai
bien choisi m'avoir on va changer le
monde c'est top génial c'était ma
première mission qu'elle kiffe
et puis attendez halal me dit bon lui si
on est bien d'accord
le handicap physique les pas de bras les
aveugles et sourds les les fauteuils
roulants tout ça pas de souci on saura
faire on mettra les moyens et pas de
problème alors par contre ceux qui
savent pas le matin qui nous fait des
câbles ou qui nous font un burn out dès
qu'on leur pose un nouveau dossier sur
leur bureau alors ça ça c'est pas
possible moi le handicap psychique j'en
veux pas
alors la douche froide
je me dis bat lucie toi qui voulais
changer le monde bah c'est pas
aujourd'hui il ya une chose que je vous
ai pas dit et qui a beaucoup contribué à
mon choix professionnel c'est que j'ai
été confronté très jeune à la maladie
psychiatrique et qu'elle a touché toute
une partie de ma famille de manière
assez violente dans ma vie il ya eu un
avant et il ya eu un après alors je vais
pas vous faire la liste de tous ceux qui
ont été concernés dans ma famille parce
que je les passerai le temps qui me
reste
mais plus sérieusement je voudrais vous
parler d'un frère de mon frère de mon
grand frère sébastien diagnostiqué d'une
schizophrénie à l'âge de 25 ans qu'est
ce que je peux vous dire sur cette
maladie
à part ça n'a rien à voir avec ce qu'on
voit dans les films c'est que c'est une
maladie terrible les crises les délires
la paranoïa
les séjours à l'hôpital psychiatrique
les médicaments qui vont qui vont plus
ceux qui font baver ceux qui font
grossir et puis à les psychiatres de
droite il ya les psychiatres de gauche
milieu il ya les psychologues la famille
totalement démunis et puis les médecins
qui vous disent batwa son ça se guérit
pas donc va falloir être patient ouais
patients pourquoi en attendant quoi on
sait pas bref
un univers de fiction qui est devenue ma
réalité
comment at il pu savoir comment at elle
pu savoir le plus déconcertant
ça a été cette cette vitre opaque qui
s'est créée entre sébastien et noue
entre lui et vous lui et les autres
c'est comme une frontière on regarde à
droite on regarde à gauche c'est
totalement infinie c'est totalement
infranchissables bien aucune issue
aucune issue et c'est surtout une
frontière que j'ai très très peur de
franchir parce qu'en fait le plus
difficile pour moi à cette non à ce
moment là ça a été ce tsunami d'émotion
qui m'a submergé jacques d'un côté
j'avais envie d'être là
j'avais envie de l'aider de
l'accompagner c'est mon frère j'avais
envie d'être une soeur aimante et d'un
autre côté mais j'acceptais pas ce qu'il
était devenu
je le reconnaissais pas j'avais honte
j'avais honte de lui en public
j'en parlais même pas mes plus proches
d'amis
et je le voyais s'enfoncer je le voyais
s'enfoncer je me sentais totalement
impuissante totalement impuissante
et ce profond sentiment d'injustice
surtout ce profond ceinture sentiment
d'injustice face à ce qui frappait ce
jeune homme brillant drôle intelligent
il était profondément bon et c'est lui
qui m'avait appris à lire comment
aurait-elle pu savoir ça j'ai été
tellement désoeuvrés j'étais tellement
désolée que j'ai commencé à avoir des
idées très noir j'ai eu envie qu'ils
disparaissent
il a fallu que je fasse le deuil d'un
être vivant
et puis il allait mieux
on a trouvé un le le bon traitement il
s'est remis à sortir et s'est remis à
travailler et s'est remis à voir ses
amis enfin ce qui restait alors je me
suis demandé je me suis demandé ce qui
m'avait amené à avoir des pensées aussi
sombre et en fait j'ai rapidement
compris que ce que est ce que j'avais
peur de ce que je connaissais pas et
qu'il fallait que je dépasse cette
ignorance pour comprendre et accepter la
situation
j'ai fini par comprendre que c'était une
maladie comme les autres
est ce que vous connaissez la définition
de la santé selon l' oms et bien c'est
un état de bien-être complet physique et
mentale qu'il y ait maladie ou pas alors
j'ai ouvert les yeux
j'ai ouvert les yeux sur cette frontière
que la société met entre le physique et
le mental
regardez je vais vous donner un exemple
très concret vous prenez deux organes
vitaux
le coeur vous fait une crise cardiaque
vous en sortez tout le monde va vous
considérez comme un survivant un warrior
vous faites une crise une crise du
cerveau qui n'est ni plus ni moins qu'un
symptôme de la maladie psychiatrique
et vous vous en sortez et blanc va se
méfier de vous on va vous regarder
bizarrement on va vous exclure c'est ce
qu'on appelle la double peine
la souffrance de la maladie et
l'exclusion vous savez qu'il ya une
enquête du samu social très récente qui
prouve que 40% au bas mot des sdf sont
en fait des personnes qui ont besoin de
soins psychiatriques et qui ont été
exclus par leurs proches par leur ami
par leur société par la société
malheureusement il ya cinq ans sébastien
a fait une terrible rechute
sa maladie a évolué et malgré tout le
travail que j'avais fait tout le travail
d'acceptation et de non jugement
et bien ce coup là j'ai craqué j'ai fait
une énorme dépression celle qui vous
colle au tapis les crises d angoisse les
attaques de panique tout est
complètement dénuée de sens plus de goût
à rien tous les petits plaisirs du
quotidien
ça a duré des mois j'avais l'impression
que ça laisse jamais s'arrêter
alors j'ai lutté de toutes mes forces je
me suis accroché j'ai continué à
travailler
j'ai continué à assurer le quotidien
comment va-t-elle peut savoir c'est
comment at elle pu le comprendre
et pourquoi moi je lui avais rien dit et
bien entouré bien entouré bien soigné je
m'en suis sorti j'ai retrouvé la pêche
la pêche légendaire
j'ai retrouvé mon humour j'ai retrouvé
le goût de vivre et là j'ai compris j'ai
ouvert les yeux sur le fait que la
souffrance psychique
elle se résume pas elle se réduit pas à
une forme de schizophrénie kiwi peut
être spectaculaire et que cette
souffrance psychique elle peut toucher
n'importe qui après un accident de la
vie un deuil une rupture amoureuse
un licenciement est d'ailleurs parmi les
éléments qui m'ont aidé à me
reconstruire pendant cette période ça a
été mon implication dans l'association
club house france qui rassemble des
centaines de personnes qui justement ont
eu un accident de la vie ou une maladie
psychiatrique
sauf que eux ils ont décidé de la
surmonter
et surtout ils ont décidé d'en parler ce
sont des combattants
ils forcent le respect qui force
l'admiration tant leur rage de vivre est
exceptionnel alors pour moi j'ai
rencontré j'ai rencontré des chefs
d'entreprise j'ai rencontré des
journalistes
j'ai rencontré des écrivains des acteurs
j'ai rencontré des gens comme vous et
moi
sauf que eh ben ils avaient décidé d'en
parler alors moi pour moi ça a été le
déclic
j'ai commencé à me réconcilier avec ma
fragilité
j'ai même commencé à l'aimer et à la
respecter alors oui bien sûr bien sûr
c'est pas facile tous les jours
mais le tout c'est de ne pas se mentir à
soi même parce que se mentir à soi-même
c'est se mettre en danger
je me souviens d'antoine antoine c'était
un jeune ingénieur brillant qui arrivait
en retard systématiquement au bureau le
matin et a duré assez longtemps il
déjeunait plus avec ses collègues le
midi ils disparaissaient parfois des
heures on savait pas où il était son
manager était complètement dépassé par
la situation
alors évidemment ses collègues eh ben
ils pensaient que c'était un paresseux
qui faisait exprès qui profitaient de la
situation peut pas avoir à faire son job
surtout que le contexte de l'entreprise
à ce moment là était compliqué alors
antoine a fini par être mis en arrêt
maladie pendant des mois mais grâce au
suivi du médecin du travail et de la drh
antoine a osé franchir le pas et il a
parlé de sa pathologie
il a repris le travail à temps partiel
le dialogue c'est renouer avec l'équipe
son manager a fait appel aux bonnes
personnes dans l'entreprise et on a
trouvé des solutions en fait antoine il
avait besoin tout simplement d'un
environnement de travail
un petit peu moins bruyants parce qu'il
fallait qu'ils puissent se concentrer et
réduire l'anxiété
il avait besoin aussi d'une journée de
télétravail par semaine voilà pour
éviter les transports en commun qui
peuvent être très stressant
et puis pouvoir un petit peu profité de
pouvoir se recentrer et il avait aussi
plus besoin de travailler avec ses
collègues d'être plus en équipe de plus
interagir avec eux et justement ses
collègues
eh ben ils ont été sensibilisés on leur
a expliqué ce que c'était qu'est-ce que
c'était ses troubles psychiques
eh bien vous savez quoi ils ont été
bluffés bluffé par le courage d'antoine
dans le parcours du combattant qui
menait depuis des années ils se sont
même dits se sont même dit que peut être
eux aussi
il avait peut-être intérêt à parler les
jours où ça l'est un peu moins bien
peut-être qu'eux aussi ils avaient
besoin d'un petit peu moins de stress
un peu plus de bienveillance un peu plus
d'attention
un peu plus de dialogue il ya une
histoire qui résume très bien que je
trouve quelqu'un est magnifique il
explique très bien ce que je viens de
vous dire les mineurs à l'époque quand
il descendait dans la mine il emmener
avec eux systématiquement une petite
cage avec un canari dedans et ce
canaries quand ces plumes commencé à
noircir eva c'était le signe qu'il
fallait rapidement sortir de la mine
parce qu'un coup de grisou allait
arriver et que tout le monde allait
exploser et bat antoine c'est ce petit
canari antoine il révèle il va révéler
ce qui se passe et ça va servir tout le
monde regardez par exemple un exemple
très concret le sms est ce que vous
savez que c'est un sourd qui a inventé
le sms pour plus communiquer avec ses
proches pour pouvoir le faire
aujourd'hui j'ai pas besoin de vous
demander de lever la main pour savoir si
vous l'utilisez voilà c'est pareil pour
les handicaps psychiques
c'est en faisant du sur mesure concerne
l'intérêt collectif
il est là notre défi et je crois même
que c'est la seule voie par laquelle on
pourra enfin remettre de l'humain dans
l'entreprise apprenons à respecter nos
fragilités apprenons accueillir celles
des autres il est là notre défi lé là
l'innovation
alors voilà j'ai juste envie de dire un
petit mot
vingt deux choses pour terminer d'abord
je veux remercier sébastien je lui dire
merci pour tout ce qu'il m'a apporté et
j'espère qu'il aura pas souffert pour
rien et puis enfin je voudrais vous
poser une dernière question si vous
voulez bien qui parmi vous a déjà connu
un trouble psychique
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]